[Music]
thank you
Prince Harry's book spare gives
excruciating details about his and his
family's lives King Charles wasn't
always a great father to him William and
Kate put him to wear that Nazi uniform
and Camilla always wanted to be a queen
according to Harry this week's magazine
Cambridge Professor David abelofia looks
at the Historical role of the royal
spare and journalist petronella Wyatt
writes in defense of Camilla the pair
joined me now
petronello and David thank you for
joining us on spectator TV now petrol to
start us off uh you write in this in the
magazine about a defense of Camilla from
Harry's attacks but before we get into
that can you tell us a bit about your
sort of reaction to Harry's book that's
come out this week and some of the
revelations that have uh that have come
from it
um yes I think it's quite
quiet coming from a member of the royal
family on two levels one being
some of the revelations are so kind of
tawdry you sort of sort of wonder
whether or not
um he thinks he's a kind of footballer
writing his Memoir or um
a TV reality star I mean I think it's
very odd to have that kind of level of
Revelations about
um sexual activity and taking drugs
coming from a member of the royal family
but my view seems to be that this is all
therapy which should never have become
public
but has become public and the other
thought that struck me is that the ghost
writer is too good he's too fluent
it's quite clearly not Harry's voice
because there are passages that are
actually very well written and lyrical
and quotes from
um great authors it doesn't quite
reflect what we know about Harry
do you get the sense maybe that um so
Harry's very very absorbed with what
sort of hurt has caused him but doesn't
rise the hurt he's causing others pass
well the external thing is the total
lack of of empathy
which suggests to me that
um he is very unhappy and says he's
extremely happy but happy people do not
try and make their family miserable and
they don't engage in spite for public
attacks so I really don't buy into his
truth of being happy because a happy
person doesn't behave like that and a
happy person is rather content with the
status quo Etc
um I mean I I think that he
is um very troubled and
has slight persecution Mania
um but yes but like a lot of people with
persecution Mania because Bertram
Russell wrote about this it's um it's a
condition in which they've failed to see
the other person's point of view
so he fails to see the Hut he's causing
to his brother to his father to Camilla
and also he's completely incapable of
apologizing but anything and keeps
demanding apologies from them
so that's um yeah it's it's
mind-boggling
and David you writes in the magazine
this week about the historical status of
spares as Harry puts himself I mean do
you think Harry's had it worse than most
when you look back in history
well I don't really I mean if you go
back to let's say the 12th century and
you had all these sons of Henry II who
were fighting one another and sometimes
fighting their father joining you know
one moment they'd be friends next moment
they'd be enemies it was very tumultuous
and what struck me very forcibly was you
know if you go back to the past of
course you find people actually taking
up arms killing people in order to try
and grab the throne and so on you can't
do that nowadays but with the modern
media we're looking at a very different
way in which a sort of princely
rebellion takes place it takes place in
public of course and it takes place
through the media through Twitter
through Netflix all that sort of thing
so it's very interesting to compare how
in the 21st century a prince might sort
of stand up and voice his objections to
um to his brother to his father and so
on a very very different world and David
what did you make of the relationship
between Harry and William is that is
that something you often see in history
is the brothers in particular who are
clashing
very much so I mean you have examples
where there's a great deal of Harmony if
I'm not mistaken Charles II and James II
they used to walk around Green Park
together in public and so on and they
seem to see one another despite you know
some differences about their religious
policies and so on they they actually
seem to have have been in some sort of
Harmony but it's a constant theme and of
course it's a constant theme because
there's so much to play for there's in
the past it's a question of power uh
it's a question of wealth all these
things which uh younger brothers might
well I'm not just talking about princes
younger brothers might very well sort of
Envy
um the elder brother because he has
automatic access to all of this so it's
quite interesting sometimes to compare
that one thing I do in my article is
sort of comparing that with the
situation where a ruler for instance
divides up his lands and among his sons
and sometimes his daughters as well but
that often doesn't solve the problem
because that just sort of sets off
competition to grab one's neighbor's
lands and so on so you're back to square
one and the next Generations in sort of
thing happened I mean Patrick the way
David says it almost seems almost
inevitable that you're gonna end up with
these fallouts with when one sort of
child is spurred does that make you feel
any sympathy for Harry at all or
anything that's pushing in
I quite agree with Davidson now this is
I think
um what used to be armies
um there's now social media and and
streaming giants like Netflix and it is
a way of rebelling Waging War or even
potentially
destroying somebody else's reputation
and as we know it can destroy people's
careers as well but
um I'm not that sorry for Harry because
I think that um spares
in the old days had a much tougher time
and also there are there are many other
cases today for example
um there are people who are the younger
sons of Dukes or Earls who see that
older brother inherit the stately home
and the title and I've known two younger
brothers
um it can't be a picnic but they've
always behaved with Grace and they
haven't made a career out of trashing
their brother because of it or their
family
and I also think that in Harry's case in
some ways it was better to be the spare
because I wouldn't want to be William
the Future King but anything in this
role I think Harry had the advantages of
having the titles of privileges without
the responsibility and that terrible
burden yeah and you write particularly
about Camilla yes do you think Harry is
being particularly unfair to Camilla is
the physical systems of her and
She's accused of being quite scheming
for example what about Ludacris
um that's absolutely ludicrous because
I've I've known her for a very long time
since I was in my late teens and
and she is absolutely incapable of
scheming and she's a very nice woman
she's very anxious about the first time
she met the boys
um she she wasn't even that Keen on
marrying Charles it was Charles who
wanted that she was keen on a more
informal Arrangement she's not
interested in the Limelight she's not
interested in titles unlike Harry who
for some weird reason
you know attacks the outdated nature of
the royal family and yet hangs on the
dear life to his titles
uh and I also think it's very
hypocritical of him because he's this
kind of he's now a new age feminist and
yet he's attacking a 75 year old woman
who can't answer back quite unpleasant
language it's very unpleasant I mean
it's the language of
um sort of Game of Thrones come Disney
fairy tales evil stepmothers it's almost
infantile strangely enough I mean David
it does seem you know you talk a lot
about sort of succession and brothers
but it also ties into sort of the
stepmother Trope there a bit doesn't it
as well with Harry and Camilla yes
absolutely I mean there are famous
examples of powerful stepmothers who go
back in his room and I've mentioned
Henry II and there's the famous Eleanor
of Aquitaine whom he married you know
things like this people who sometimes
manage women who manage to exercise
enormous power and who could sort of
play around with sons stepsons and so on
and dangled all sorts of offers in front
of them so that's been that's been a
constant really yes but Harry
um in Harry's case I mean
Camilla has nothing to dangle in front
of him no no
she doesn't have anything he wants she
has no lands at her disposal she can't
put him on the throne instead of his
brother but a very interesting point you
make about Eleanor because eventually
though Henry got fed up and locked her
up so
we're looking at that
I want to tell you that to Harry at some
point
you mentioned your piece as well
petronella that this is the first time
we've seen Harry speaker away from Megan
for quite a long time do you think maybe
people have been a bit unfair to Megan
perhaps I know a lot of this is Harry's
own doing any sort of problems I've
revised my opinion of Megan I've also
heard from a very good source that it
was Harry who did more of the screaming
and yelling at staff when they were
working Roz and it was Megan who had to
calm him down this is completely you
know this is a scoop I haven't told
anyone about this
um so I think that she is much calmer
more conciliary and I think it's our
part that Harry has lived with their
sort of bitterness and and anger ever
since his mother's death and he hasn't
been able to get rid of it because um
that I mean everything is done with
Megan what the Netflix thing was
it was pretty harmless and it was all
sort of
um it was like home and garden
yeah very Californian but this is this
is bile stuff you know this is
hatred fueled stuff and I I don't think
it's coming from Megan at all
could I then ask I mean where Patronella
do you think you get some of his
vocabulary from because he's been
talking in these interviews about
unconscious bias and it does seem to me
that some of the language how could I
put this politely is is a little Beyond
his normal sort of yes I think I think a
lot of his new language definitely comes
from Megan
um Russ comes from The Ghost Writer
um
but yes he would never have heard of
unconscious bite I mean he was basically
um a kind of upper class oik
um and a pretty sexist one
and I think Megan has
um yeah she's got him to buy into the
whole California
um
staff and and the therapy stuff and
whatever but I don't think you can blame
her for this what a bitterness that
seems to go right back to his childhood
and although Megan in a way has
facilitated this
um because she's very much a person who
wants
to tell her truth or believes in letting
everything come out rather than the
British way of keeping everything inside
and just soldiering on she's facilitated
it yeah I absolutely agree and you're
right
so I don't think she's created this um
well little monster that now emerges
what do you think the uh the major
audience is here I mean how do we
balance the American audience against
the British audience and of course
there's a worldwide audience as well but
just thinking of those two audiences one
of whom perhaps Megan might be
addressing more is that possible and
Harry Moore yeah can't get to the
British audience yes I think when it's
Megan she's very conscious of addressing
an American audience and I think Harry
is trying to settle scores and therefore
is very much aimed at his family and a
British audience but the trouble is that
he's gone too far and
we don't really like our royal family
being trashed in this way by a very
privileged young man during a cost of
living crisis uh and I think he has gone
too far and and even with the Americans
because I think the American Media are
now making total fools out of him yeah I
was going to come back to that I mean to
David your excellent point about these
being sort of the modern weapons of war
these sort of social media and press
attacks I mean do you think they're
backfiring as well now on the couple
I I think they are I mean I think that
um so maybe with the leaking of what was
in the book which I must admit I haven't
read
um but I've got a treat
[Laughter]
so much of that just sort of pouring out
and dominating the media for days and
days days and and of course the point
that kept coming across was well the
royal family won't reply and in a
sentence can't reply it wouldn't be
right to reply and that dignified
silence I think actually is winning the
royal family a lot of symptoms yes it
definitely sorry the simple fact we have
a new king and he's made in my view an
excellent start to his his Reign and
everyone is of course Very sympathetic
to him and and seeing how he's adapted
from being Prince of Wales to to being
king
um and he's not in a sense not being
given a chance you know the coronation
hasn't even taken place
brilliant thank you very much David and
thank you petronella thank you
[Music]